el partido islamista que ha gobernado
marruecos en los últimos diez años se ha
desplomado en las elecciones
legislativas regionales y municipales
que se celebraron ayer el partido de la
justicia y el desarrollo como se llama
esta formación es el único partido
islamista legal aquí en marruecos y
ahora aparte de haber perdido el poder
en el parlamento también ha lo han
perdido a nivel regional y a nivel local
ya todos los analistas auguraban un
retroceso importante para la formación
pero al final resultó ser una caída sin
precedentes ahí quedaron en octavo lugar
y los motivos que explicarían a esta
gran caída son a la crisis interna que
sufre el partido pero sobre todo el gran
descontento popular ante la crisis
social y económica que atraviesa el país
y también la nueva ley electoral que
favorece a los partidos minoritarios y
el gran vencedor de las elecciones fue
el reagrupamiento nacional de
independientes una formación liberal
integrada por empresarios y altos cargos
de la administración y liderada por el
actual ministro de agricultura ají
sandwich quien es además el empresario
más adinerado del país durante la noche
el ministerio facilitó nuevos datos que
llego al 50 por ciento un poco mayor que
en 2016 aún así no deja de ser baja pues
existe un contexto de desinterés por la
política institucional y por otra parte
diversos partidos mayoritarios entre
ellos los islamistas denunciaron
irregularidades en la campaña y acusan
al partido ganador de haber comprado los
votos